[Music]
the whole thing I was in and out in an
hour and a half hmm yeah and that's all
you hear and it's annoying because it's
like it's just [__] Burgers and Fries
why does it take so long I don't know
nice but everyone says like the
procedure is super short yeah and so you
think okay it's easy
but it's like for anyone I don't know I
feel like for any normal person like
anything to do with their eyes is like a
very squeamish thing right so I walked
in they did like all the final tests
they were like test your eyes again to
make sure because it's been like months
since my consultation so I had to like
test my eyes again to make sure my
prescription hasn't changed or anything
and then he comes in and he's like all
right you ready to [__] do this and I
was like God dang I'm [__] scared
and he was like here take this Valium
and a Motrin
see Pop those back right and then he's
like telling you about the surgery he's
like I'm gonna walk you through I'm
gonna guide you through the whole thing
so you know what's going on and
meanwhile valium's kicking in you know
and then they bring you to this room and
she was like she's like oh and by the
way I'm gonna give you a teddy bear so
you can hold it
I was like okay okay so I'm holding this
bear like lying in this thing he puts
you down and then he like covers up the
left eye because they're starting on the
right eye he puts numbing drops in and
then
he he's like basically like you're gonna
feel a lot of pressure and they like
clamp your eye open and then do you see
like the red circles
on my eye
um oh yeah so why is that eye going the
other way that's really scary
they put this circular thing in and they
like press it down and that's the thing
that like makes the slit in your eye
and you just feel a lot of pressure on
your head like something's just like and
you're you go blind for a second he's
like all right the hard part's over and
then you're like Wheels you over to the
the laser part
and you watch him like take the flap off
your like you can see still and you he
like takes the flap off and you can see
your vision changes it gets blurrier and
then he starts lasering and you can
smell like burning eye
so the whole time I'm like is this is
there like someone's bear burning or
something like that nah that's your eye
yeah it's your eye whoops we went too
deep hits your brain
sorry
[Laughter]
and then and then they put the flap back
over and you can see it go like by the
way while they're lasering your vision
is like getting better
you can see it changing like your focal
length or whatever and then he puts the
flat back over and you can watch that
and then basically you can see and then
he patches that up does the other one
and then
like the whole thing took 15 minutes but
the whole time I was shaking because I'm
[__] so scared and then they
basically give you like they give you
some glasses tell you to go home they
give you a um an Ambien and they say
take this and just sleep for six hours
so I'm [__] faded off Valium and then
take this Ambien I wasn't having dude it
was the best sleep of my [__] life
course yeah best leave my life you see
why they snort it hey yeah ambien or
Valium any of it
snorting ambient will be [__] crazy
they're opiates right an ambient is just
a sleeping pill I don't know no a Valium
is like a Xanax oh it's like a lighter
Xanax oh okay and then you wake up and
you can see you're still like a little
bit sensitive to light and [__] but like
I basically went right back to my
computer and started working
nice yeah just seven hours again yeah
yeah Kelsey's like are you sure you
should be looking at your screen I'm
like you're like yeah no I'm good I'm
chilling yeah yeah yeah well congrats
man you made it yeah thanks have you
even testing it out just looking at
things yeah I've been looking at a ton
of [__]
I've been looking at a ton of [__]
yeah like far into the distance like
medium yeah like this is pretty cool
looking at you
you saw your kids that you've never seen
before you're like oh ew whoa yeah what
the [__] is going on here when did you
guys move in uh yeah see I can do this e
f p t o z l p e d p e c f d e d f Q
that's right I told you about that
gray spot in my vision my left eye yeah
um
so I worked out last week and I finally
got the liquid in there to move around a
little bit nice because uh my trainer
had me push the sled in the street
and uh
I try to be a tough guy
I'm like yeah
ran that thing up the street pushed it
back down like I'm good bro that was
easy there you go
yeah
I'm like about a yak okay
dab him up I get inside Barrel inside I
just fall fall and curl up and I go oh
[__] I'm with you really yeah because we
had just done some strength training
before okay
he was uh
yeah my trainer is this
um
you know ripped ass Swedish dude
and uh I watched the guy squat like 205
like it's [__] 40 pounds dude I did I
did squats with the bar and you were
hurting two days ago I can't or
yesterday yeah I can't walk today yeah
yeah
um literally it's not embarrassing it's
so sad because pre-tor dude I hit like
that PR
I did like 195 or some [__] I was like I
don't [__] [__] I'll eat two
cheeseburgers next week I'm Gonna Knock
it yeah now I'm where you're at doing
115 like
[Laughter]
that video that kid hitting the [__]
people Cody it's Cody let's go Cody
and he goes
airpods fly up bro it was 90 pounds
yeah yeah I'm right there with you man
um
but yeah so then I think the [__] I
think the pressure from pushing the sled
and like having my neck like up it just
like squeezed my eye a little bit and
just got it out so now
before you were like out of this eye
you're like bubbled no you're saying it
fixed it it like because there's liquid
in there I already went and got a scan
oh I see and it's just in there oh I see
and so you squeeze in the right way and
then it just kind of like just it
displaced it oh that's sick so now out
of this I I can see you now you're just
kind of like gray and wavy yeah I had a
dude I had a scary morning where I like
woke up and my right eye was like shut
and I rolled over to shut off my alarm
and you know the yellow alarm button
yeah it was [__] red oh
I was like switching eyes like did they
just use the software yeah
it freaked me the [__] out I'm like oh
oh I'm going blind this is it for me you
can see I'm happy for you
25 years of wearing contacts and glasses
and you feel like do you feel like a new
person
I mean literally the only thing like
contacts
like I've never thought that the
contacts were like that much of like an
impediment on my life
like literally the only thing that's
changed now is like when I wake up in
the morning I can see I don't have to
like go to the bathroom and put my
contacts in which is really nice yeah
and I think the other huge change
that's gonna be great is opening my eyes
underwater ah I know it seems like how
how long have you been wearing glasses
yeah yeah go find that submarine man
yeah exactly so I can finally see the
wreckage yeah swim two and a half miles
down yeah
no but like you know I haven't opened my
eyes in a pool
in [__] 25 years I don't even know
what it feels like so that's gonna be a
it's gonna be huge because the chlorine
just gets into the cut and it blinds you
no don't say that
hey you laughing what the [__] you
laughed all those dead submarine people
you got to bring it back okay